there's a difference between what
i think single men want yeah in
relationships versus what single mothers
want from so your mothers want a step
yeah earlier on you you want that guy to
come in and and look after you because
that would be the natural order of
things the man heads your family whether
that be the biological man to your
children or another one the extra man is
what i would call him um you call him
the extra man the extrovert he's always
going to be extra because he's never
going to come first right he's not the
biological dad the kid knows that the
mum knows that
but i find that men especially myself i
speak for myself
i don't expect any woman to walk into my
life and say
i'm i'm expected to be a stepmom and
i'll make that very clear like i make it
very clear
this is my responsibility
if you want to take part
and it gets to that point
and you meet my child and you want to go
there you can
but it's not an expectation correct and
i think that's where you have the
jadedness that you have from men that
try to avoid single mums
because
there is that expectation whether women
want to want to admit it or not
that they must step up to the mark yeah
and feel the void that the alpha the bad
boy left behind right
but i think also when it comes to men
and avoiding single mums
you know i'm 24 right now i'm taking my
prime physically in terms of my own
potential you know there's still time to
go there but
the way i i look at is why would i want
to
get um go into a family that's already
somewhat built and have to have to fill
that role when i can you know find
someone who doesn't have a kid build my
own home and again like you were saying
before you know i have certain rights to
that kid in terms of how i discipline
him how i do certain things what he um
their
their routine whereas when it's not my
child fair enough i can love that kid
but the moment of mum doesn't love me
anymore it's done it's finished you're
right so you're right and you have no
rights to the kids after
so like i've talked to um guys that have
raised a kid for like 10 years or five
years and and they fall in love with the
kid and then
it's over and they can't see the kid
anymore
i had to deal with that myself i had to
deal with it i had to it's a double
breakup
right so you break up with the mother
and you also break up with a child and
it's like well i've raised you for this
long and now i'm not even allowed to see
like you became my child do you know
what i mean and so it's like
and that's one of the reasons why i tell
men if they do get with women who are
single mothers you need to understand
exactly what you're getting yourself
into you know do you think that the
stepdads should be able to adopt the
kids if they're in the home more than
the actual dad
um no
i would say that might depend on the
child
because of how important is for a man to
be in the home i think
that might be the way to go
because again you know father's stop
children um stop sons from ending up in
prison you know if if if a child is a
scammer a drug dealer or is involved in
any form of deplorable activity that
could land him in prison it tends to be
because the father isn't there you know
if uh if a daughter ends up you know in
any form of sex work again it tends to
be because
you know the father isn't there and so
if a man is there you know a
stepfather is there and he's he's
stepping up then i i think it makes
sense
for that child to have the stability of
you know be knowing i am adopted by this
man this man is basically my father now
what do you guys think
i think there's potential risks if you
well it depends on the um status of the
relationship i i would personally be
married to the person
um i wouldn't take any risk because you
never know what their intentions are
you've got a young kid you never know if
they're you know rapists and stuff like
that so that's one that's one aspect of
it but i would
agree with you and say that a paternal
figure in a household is essential in
terms of parenting
and
yeah
so i would agree
i also think that the child should have
some say at a certain age
um
because if the biological father is
still stepping up to the plate in some
way shape or form then i feel like then
like if the child is old enough they
should have some kind of say because if
they're adopted or not it won't stop the
person being around and if they're of
age they can make that decision to go
and see them if they're even if they're
not adopted um so i think it really
depends situationally
yeah i agree with both of you guys um
the marriage you know if you're married
to the person you are building up your
future with them
they're you know they've been there for
the child um i'd say five six plus years
the child's you know of age where that
you know that they can have a say in the
process um i do think the
adoption um
would be um essential and beneficial for
for the household and an option
that should be um
yeah that could that could happen do you
think the child the father should be
able to adopt a child
i don't it's a it's a tough question
right because i i think of things from
both sides so on one hand um i i don't
really want to see rights taken away
from the biological debt right
which is why i think it's really
important that it starts at 50 50
custody right but if it's a situation
where it's like an every other weekend
type of thing right
and the step-dad's in the house more
than the actual dad i mean it kind of
makes sense
because he's going to have a bigger
impact than the actual dad yeah but the
child this is the thing about that the
child always knows who their biological
father is you could raise a child for
years
right
and that child could not know their
actual biological father but they know
you're not it do you think
kids that are dads that are raising kids
that aren't theirs it's the same
that's a raisin kids yeah they say um
there's some studies that say like 20 25
of men are raising a child that's not
actually theirs yeah that's very true
yeah what one in 25 fathers might not be
the biological yeah one in 20
i mean it might be lower one he says one
in
what i'm asking in those in those
situations what do you do you think the
kids know no the kids don't know
okay
you're saying does the child know that
this person is not their biological
father yeah because you said like the
kid knows deep down right no i'm not
it's not a deep down thing i'm saying
that
the mother always
the mother's told the child at some
point in time that they've got a dad
right
if a new man arrives the mother's not
going to say oh this is your dad this is
i don't know uncle whoever or this is my
friend or whatever that child still
knows that's not their dad they know
they have one and they know that that
new person is not not the daddy so i
have another question for you guys do
you think because like women we have the
right to an abortion do you think men
should have the right to a financial
abortion
can you explain that so a financial
abortion is basically um
when so if i'm pregnant right i can say
oh i don't want to be a mother and i can
have an abortion do you think men that
don't want to be fathers should say you
know what i don't want to be on the hook
for child support i don't want to have
anything to do with this kid and if it
was up to me she would get an abortion
but she's not so i want to sign a reign
sign away my rights do you guys think
that men should be able to do that
i think that's fair okay i mean if they
don't get a say
um in the abortion and they have like
clearly stated i i don't want you to
have this child
um
why not okay i agree i feel like that's
a lot of the issues that we have today
as well with regards to that um
yeah i feel like
there need to be um they should have an
input
yeah i'm so quite 50 50 because if
you've agreed to have the child then
but they didn't they didn't agree yeah
so basically um
he says he wants her to get an abortion
she says no but since she has the right
to say she doesn't want to be a mother